When people talk about you, they usually think like, "Yeah, that
guy's like a sociopathic
loser who's like just like super psychotic and his community
is known as a bunch of harassers." I think it's just an example
of your nar. You think there is there a chance that she's just
Is there a chance that she didn't feel that at the time? No,
no, no, it is. And I'm like, so all right, I'm just going to
throw it out there. Do you feel like you handled Anna correctly
for one? Um, and I don't think that was good for a your public
perception and b her mental health either.
Playing into his narrative. The guy's narrative was about bridges
and professional arguing with him for no reason. No, that's not
anybody's narrative. They're saying No, no, no, no, no. They
were saying he he burns bridges with like people professionally.
No, I don't mean he has a bridge with anyone in chat. It is the
You're not even listening to the words I'm saying. Okay, say
your words, Kelly. He's the He's responding with like how his
life is hollow, right? That part I'm also and he's arguing.
Does he just like pick on our new mods? I don't think he's picking.
So Androider said you can have successful career
and also lose all your meaningful relationships. Sounds pretty
hollow.
We're going to leave this one. It's already GG on the floor.
It is what it is. Okay. What? By who? I love I love that clip.
Ban that guy. Who is It's the Dan. Ban that guy. He like points
at the chat. Oh yeah. Is Android a girl. Android is a girl. Yeah.
Oh, okay. Unfortunately, she's Australian, but All right. We
don't have many of those female mods. All right. Stop speaking
to them. Leave Destiny alone. All right. We can't. She's she
took out the last. Who is the last? Uh, never mind. Drama. Why
would you think you have access to every single person, friendship,
relationships I have? Especially when the majority of the ones
I've made over the past couple of years been offline. Are you
married or something? How's your friend group doing? Seeing as
you're here gossiping on a Saturday night, but he's doing the
same thing.
Jesus. Why? Uh why should I drag Chris lettuce in? VP just said
you should drag Chris Lettuce in. Why? Because uh no, there's
nothing nothing good's going to come out of Chris Lettuce. I
promise you. I like Chris Bett lettuce. I just He's send that
one back to DJ.
No. No, no, no, no. It's
I'm just kidding. Damn, Jerry. You just like getting rid of people.
It just feels like the Spider-Man meme where everyone's pointing
at each other when people in the server call each other losers
for not going out of sip, man. He added me and told me to notice
him. So, that was my best attempt. I'm so sorry then. It's okay.
Oh, let me see. A big egg. It's an ostrich egg or an emoon. Oh
my god. Nope. That is an ostrich egg. I want it. What is I don't
like that. Okay. Reading this real uh having a very successful
life with a number of the with a number of controversies that
make you or a number of controversies that make you look at best
antisocial and at worst manipulative and sociopathic isn't exactly
a W. Why would you think you have access to every single person
every single person's friendship relationships I have? Especially
when the majority of the ones I've made over that Kelly read
this over the past couple of years have been offline. Are you
married or something? How's your friends group? How's your friend
group doing? Seeing as how you're here in in here gossiping on
a Saturday night. Yeah, I think Destiny would just argue that.
They don't pay attention. There'd have been many
Amumu has replied as well and I don't know what he's saying.
Yeah, Mumu's fighting with him, too. It's good times.
By the way, I feel like he's he's made both of these points like,
well, I'm a public figure, so all of my things are out there.
Obviously, people are going to care about it. Um, but also to
the extent that these people care is like, I don't care. I hope
that Destiny tears this guy. I hate Emory. They got they have
the conversation in here, but I don't know if he's still arguing
with Emory because Amumu is coming after him now, too. I don't
I can't even tell if this is I can't either. I'm Why would you
think you have Oh, it's the Destiny's message back to Emory.
Stfoo in this BS and answer the drama question. Is it weird to
open a conversation by telling a woman she looks like a specific
OF model? Oh, he's just making a joke. And then Destiny, this
guy. Weird question. Wait, is Emry a Mr. Girl fan? Uh, maybe.
I don't know. [__] Why? He's a Queen fan. I know.
Okay. Imagine
being a Mr. Girl fan in 2024. It's kind of sad. I don't know.
His new music video was pretty lit. I liked it. What are we looking
for? Mr. Pascal asking for mod. I don't know if that's going
to happen. That's a guy who repeats he hates women like eight
times a day. Mr. Pascal is very lucky that he's back in this
Discord after Rage Pope decided to cross server ping me about
your ban. You're very lucky you're back. No, Rage Pope, take
him back. Load tax.
Apparently, he thinks I murdered Lotax or something. The guy
is obsessed on Hinge. Who the is Low Tax? Anyone? That was Destiny's
message. I don't know. Oh, Lot. Yeah, Loax would have been Wait,
are you sure it's not Etekica?
Pretty Tony, are you sure it's not Etekica? Who are these names?
Somebody Somebody messaged Destiny before they went to commit
and this Emory guy holds it against him. Why? Maybe it's low
tax. I don't know who Low Tax is. Oh, yeah. I showed all these
already. Um, or have I shown? Listen, if he is a sociopath, like
that's just he you don't even get to decide if you're a sociopath,
you know? Yeah, it just happens to you. Sucks. Oh, right. Low
tax ran something awful. Okay. Okay. Okay. Yeah. I didn't think
Destiny knew Etica. Sorry. I was just like I knew it was someone
who killed themselves. I just Listen, I wasn't big on the internet
in terms of like 2018 to 2021 or so. Maybe 2017 to 2021.
I know no lower from that part of the internet. Someone tag Jtock
in this, please. Like, I don't know. I'm looking at the Discord
kind of, but you guys like Oh, never mind. Don't worry about
it, Tony. I don't know if you're listening. Don't worry about
it. This is a good meme. I like this. What mean? That's disgusting.
Oh, great. Emory is using me in an argument. We love that. Against
my own will. That's not even what I said anyway. Didn't even
ask the victim for approval. My gosh, that's a spicy one from
memory. I would like it if everyone could stop uh using me in
one way or another. That would be good. Please stop. Stop taking
the words that come out of my mouth and twisting them weirdly.
Think I live my life by is known as. Bro, you're literally [__]
Mr. Girl fan. A guy who's known as a What even is this claim?
So, this is saying like Destiny's known as something. And obviously
that's not a claim that somebody who likes Mr. girl would be
uh making cuz maybe I don't I don't necessarily agree with the
ped or the part but Mr. Girl is definitely known as a whether
that's fair or not is obviously up for debate. Imagine letting
the live rent free in your head after his report so obviously
failed because you know deep down every single thing written
there is just asap is just just as capitulation of your weirdo
ass behavior. so rentree that you have to scream at Kelly because
she may have accidentally agreed with that narrative in a small
channel called Spicy Chat of All Things. Bro, you aren't a millionaire.
Why do you care? Or bro, aren't you a millionaire? Sorry. Why
do you care about these nobodyies that are what these nobies
are saying about you? Unless you're worried that's going to that's
going to trigger a response, I think. Emry should join VC. Emory,
join the waiting channel. I'll drag you in. Destiny will hop
in for sure. Don't have this in Don't have this in text, dude.
go wrong. Don't have this argument in text. Okay, get in the
VC. I agree. I only agree with white blood cells as a descriptor
if you're taking it literally because like you're you don't if
you're a body, you don't control your white blood cells, right?
They just attack things and sometimes they go rogue. If you have
an autoimmune disease, they're like too spicy. And if you have
cancer, they're not good at all. Well, actually, the other way
around. Oh, no.
Steroids. steroids, riddle immune, chemo for a cancer. Either
way, your white blood cells are a bit weird. Who's a white blood
cell right now? I will not speak. Besides, some of the orbiters
have been like white blood cells, but I don't necessarily like
dislike them as a whole. It's not even like it's also just a
little weird to call it all the time. It's a little weird to
call all of your white blood cells were all up at once, will
you? You No, no, no. It's also just how people treat their friends.
People defend their friends. It's just like a fact of life. Yeah.
The white blood cell thing with Mr. Girl was that there was like
a financial incentive for those people to defend Destiny. That's
more like what it's talking about. So that's why I'm saying
that's why did you not listen to anything I just said? If you
took it as like a literal analogy, it would be good. But I don't
know the law and then other people seem to imply it's more like
um Mr. Girl seems to more imply it's more like he does he has
like a pack of dogs that he sends out which doesn't fit with
a white blood cell analogy. If you were going to take it more
literally of what that would, you know, represent. Let's go.
Wait a minute. Destiny is actually going to come in. I Oh, I
can finally hear it just fine now. What the he wanted? Wait,
why did you want me in? All right. Well, don't I cuz if you're
going to talk about Destiny, you might as well uh let him come
join this VC and then argue this out over voice. People don't
seem to listen to the things that I say. I said if we took white
blood cells as like removing whatever the Mr. Golish said then
analogy can work. I don't know what Mr. Gisha said. I'm taking
it more as more of a literal representation of how it could work.
Um hey so just before uh the big event um how are we feeling
about Sea of Thieves tonight? Uh I'll play Sea of Thieves if
you're on once I'm done the stream. Yeah. The issue is I have
to leave for like half an hour in like 3 hours or like 2 hours.
So timing might be awkward, but I would really like to. Also,
I would love for you to play with us, Kelly. That is not going
to happening. And this feels like it could have been a DM. Well,
listen. It is what it is. Hold on. Look, look at the stream.
And then tell me what you think of that avatar versus there's
two versions. What do you mean? You got to look at the stream.
Oh, [__] Yeah, the one with the big ears I am going
to like more just cuz it's like more accurate character. We'll
just do the big ears one. Oh yeah, you would have seen both.
Okay. Yeah. Okay. Have fun. Cool. Yeah. See you. No, if it was
literal it would be a goon analogy, but not I don't know what
the Mr. Girl says in his and I'm not really interested in looking
at Mr. Girl lore. Okay, sure. Spitmeister, thank you for the
five gifted and kick chat and showing me that my gifts are broken
for some reason. I can't tell if I just have them turned down
too much. It showed up on stream, so I think I might just have
it turned down too much to hear. Definitely said give him five
minutes
two minutes ago. So, can I get a cool avatar like that? I think
I earned it. I'm sorry, sick boy. That's going to be $25 for
the big wolf gang guy. What happened?
What did he do? Sick boy subscribe. No, it's just the the price
of the avatars. Just the price of them. Yeah. No, no, no. He's
not paying for an unbanned. It's just the price of the avatars.
Okay, fair. Oh man, awesome. I want to play music, but I can't
play. Ah, it's going to get copyrighted. Why would you have any
music when you have me? True. Kelly, start singing for everybody.
They want to hear donated $10. Oh, somebody just donated. Let's
go. Necro, thank you. Uh, $10 super chat. Let's go. I don't know
why my audio isn't coming through now. Subs just
I think I did. Wait, did we get We got five gifted. I think them.
Yeah, we're good then. Yeah. Yeah, we good. We good. Is there
an image for me? Wes, possibly. Okay. I think Do I have one left?
Wolf Gang witches. Is that a song? I have no clue. You can You
can do Wes for the last one. Okay. Okay. I'm sure we're going
to end up doing more anyway.
I don't know it. My bad. Oh, should I get another drink before
Destiny comes here? Yeah, I'm thinking yeah. I I can hear everything.
I'm just walking away for a second. The reality is white blood
cells more often than not don't do it for Destiny's sake. A lot
of them do it to farm chat. Yeah, but that's the same with white
blood cells, right? They can just go rogue for any number of
reasons. There can be some kind of weird going on with your blood
cells, right? Maybe your bone is like maybe you're really sick
and you have a nasty ass infection and they're all through the
roof. I don't know, man. Maybe he does have some cancers that
need to be cut out. But uh hope it's not me. If I was a cancer,
what kind would I be? I don't know. I don't I don't think I would
be very one of the destructive ones. I am a blood cancer. No,
I wouldn't be a blood cancer.
Brain cancer and a blood cancer.
That seems a bit mean. I feel like I would be like a cancer or
something. Not very important.
Just testicular cancer. Prostate cancer is pretty pointless.
That doesn't really many people. I could take that one. Lung
cancer. Incurable cancer isn't a type of cancer. Let's just It's
progressed to a point where your hands passes the bloodb brain
barrier. All right. Brilliant. Childhood leukemia because she's
just as welcome when you find out she's around. Does that mean
I need a buzzfeed or cancer you quiz? True. talking to you losers
cuz nobody else is for sakes. Bowel cancer is on the rise. That
could be a possibility apparently. Kelly, why are you so mean
to us? What the [__] did I do? I told him to make
sure he read out your subs that you gifted like twice. Am I mean
to I'm I'm back. I'm just going to say uh when once this starts
I might drop the size of the channel down quite a bit if Destiny
I don't know if Destiny's still coming but if he's coming and
he does join I'm probably I might drop the size of the channel
and then if you guys are if it starts to turn any kind of dog
pile on Emory as I suspect it could I am probably going to start
moving people out. Okay, so just chill. Let Destiny and Emory
argue and don't because I know this obviously like a pro DG space.
So I don't want him to get dogpiled just for having an argument
in this VC. Pancreatic cancer and throat cancer.
So anyway, who was that like passive aggressive to say who you
kicking out? What? I'm not kicking anybody out as long as they're
not speaking up. But why do you need the room full of so random
people can't join in and like anybody who is that likely happening?
Yeah, there are like 10 people there. Uh yeah, but if somebody's
watching the stream for some reason they want to hop in and scream
some not going to happen.
Speak in minion language. What does that mean? Well, there's
Destiny just like Okay, so I wasn't able to follow entirely all
of the argument here. Did you have some problems with the way
Destiny manages his life? Is that the gist of it here,
Well, I think What am I in here for? I don't know. You guys were
having a argument in text chat on a Saturday night, so why not
have it in a VC on Saturday night? Somebody told me to join and
I said I' And I guess I said I'd join. I'm not actually sure
what I'm arguing with this guy about though. Whatever you guys
were arguing, Mr. Girl, or Yeah, yeah, go. Whatever you wanted
to start it off with, I guess. Well, Emry, you started typing
stuff and then Destiny responded. So, why don't you go over what
you were typing, what your criticisms were, and then Destiny
can respond. Sure. I think it would be fair to say that you have
the Bridgeurner kind of moniker for a
Are we arguing about like what the public perception of me is?
Well, yeah, that was kind of our argument, right? Is like the
public peression perception is that you have like relationships
decaying. Like what are the over the past like two years? Like
what are the big bridges that I've burned over the past two years?
Britney Simon for one.
Uh I think Cherry I I don't want to speak for Cherry. Um probably
a little bit more than that. Uh but you kind of like go back
and forth a lot of people as well. So do you think I've maintained
or created better relationships like professional and otherwise
this year or do you think I've lost more? Uh, I can't speak to
all your professional relationships, but I can just speak to
a pattern that I've seen of like a lot of a lot of bridge burning,
a lot of like just small fights turning into bigger fights when
they don't need to be. I think you like react to people very
poorly. Okay. So, for do you think that like for instance uh
do you think my relationship with Lex Freiedman has been positive
or do you think that's been negative? I think it's been mostly
positive, but that's mostly because it's professional and you
guys don't really talk that often as my relationship with
Abba has been mostly positive or negative. Also, sorry, go ahead.
Do you think my relationship with ABBA has been mostly positive
or negative? I would imagine positive on on the screen, but also
one of the relationships obviously I didn't didn't feel like
it was necessary to bring up because I think everyone knew it,
but it was like Molina as well. So, okay. So, do you think that
my um relationships with you think like Kyla and Nick or Pixie
or Lyken and Aaron or the people with Progressive Victory? Um
or the online like political friends that I've got. So, like
Josiah, Loner Box, I'm really important. Do like any of these
count or do you think any of these that I brought up are compromised
or so the general criticism is that usually that if you find
any little issue
uh you blow up that little issue or the person will react in
a way that you perceive as worse and then it starts to blow up.
So, uh, all the,
um,
previous
relationships seem to have decayed pretty fast because, uh, it's,
uh, tumultuous. Like, I think you haven't I had, haven't I had
boundaries? Yeah, sure. Haven't I had issues with ABBA and that
we've argued about things? We're fine, right? Yeah. I've had
issues with like me and I think even like Kyle and Nick, we've
argued about some stuff. Nothing like super serious, but I think
we're pretty fine. Me and Pixie used to have huge fights online.
remember the Joe Biden Tara Reed stuff? That was a huge argument.
I think we're fine. Uh Lykan and me over the Palestinian stuff
have had huge fights. And then Aaron kind of as well in the background.
I think we're all fine. Um I'm sure I can dig through a lot of
these people. We've had arguments and disagreements on things
and I think Lonerbox made a video critiquing my debate with Omar
where he said I did bad on a couple of points that he brought
up. Pisco and me have had vicious fights. Um,
like Joanne I think is more pro Palestinian. She's mentioned
things that I've said that she doesn't agree with. I mean, do
you disagree with any of these or I don't disagree with you that
like obviously there have been some people that I'm no longer
friends with or we've had huge fights that have blown up end
the friendship but like I feel like I've had a lot of positive
relationships here like overwhelmingly more than ones that have
kind of fallen apart. Uh, so I think it's weird that like the
idea or the impression of like oh my god this guy's like burning
bridges all the time when I don't really think for like the past
like two years I don't think that's been the case. I feel like
you put up that front of like I'm willing to burn bridges all
the time and that's for a reason, right? Because out of like
I guess everyone in this call, I would imagine you have like
burnt the most kind of like friendships whether you I've been
a content creator that has been Yeah, I've been a highly public
content creator for 15 years. So I probably burnt more and made
more like 10 times over than most the other people in here. Sure.
Okay. Do you think do you think you react a lot more strongly
than you need to at times for instance? Uh I don't generally
think so but I mean I'm sure there have been times where I have
reacted more strongly than I should have. Sure. So all right
I'm just going to throw it out there. Do you feel like you handled
Anna correctly for one? Um there's probably things I could have
done better. That was an exceptionally
uh wild ride. But see, I feel like what most people I'm not sure
from the public perception from when I when I watched all that,
most people didn't really seem to give you the advice that I
think was like very necessary, probably very too apparent is
that when she was getting uh a little crazy, is that
uh you had her blocked. That was the correct thing. But then
when she was contacting other people, uh I think you should have
imposed a more stronger boundary of, hey, just block her. I'll
explain why. It seemed to be a continuous snowball effect of
bringing her on stream over and over again because she would
contact other people.
And I don't think that was good for a your public perception
and b her mental health either. Oh, also her public perception,
of course. Okay. Is that your biggest criticism is that I didn't
deal with a 30-year-old woman in the ideal way what two or three
years ago or how long ago the stuff that that's part of that's
part of the thing. But there's stuff that you do as well where
you say you basically suggest you're going to like leak her nudes
as well. So that's one of Don't really think I suggest I'm going
to leak her nudes. I think I like jokingly suggested that in
response to her saying she was going to start leaking I think
either my nudes or my or something. But I mean, obviously, I
don't think I've ever I don't think I've ever I don't think I've
ever leaked anybody's stuff like that ever, despite other people
apparently having fun leaking stuff on me. But I think it would
be fair to say that me and you know that's not true. I think
you definitely were. And I understand definitely was what? I
understand through your perspective that Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I definitely was what? Wait, cuz I remember you said that if
she leaks out something like that, which is personal, that's
like a like a boundary. Yeah, sure. I might have something like
that. Yeah. In response to Yeah. Wait, wait, hold on. In response
to Yeah. what she was saying, but like I didn't do that. And
even though she did do that, by the way, she did leak that, I
still didn't leak it. So, I mean, I think if anything, I think
the the actual record would show that I wasn't serious when I
said that because I was serious. I would have just leaked everything
she sent me, which I didn't. I think you did probably think about
it strongly, but that's great. But you have literally no evidence
of that. But again,
um like I like she did and I didn't. So you can like say you
can invent in this fantastical world all these things I contemplated
but I didn't. So I don't know how how am I possibly supposed
to counter what you're saying when the record exonerates me and
now you're saying well there's another world where you considered
it. think it would be fair for people to think that you strongly
probably considered that but probably went against it for your
own public interest or I just didn't do it because it literally
gets me nothing because you have done it in the past and that's
what got your nudes leaked. So what first of all no I've never
publicly leaked anybody's anything ever. Number one. Number two.
Yeah, you kind of did cuz you spreaded it with your friends and
now it's not public public, but it is with a social uh uh click
where she did not intend those nudes to be leaked. That's another
person. So, number one, you have no idea what the background
spread around people's nudes. So, it's not really you have no
idea what any of the background on this is. Probably because
the only thing you've read is Mr. Girls report on it. So, number
one, okay, those news never leaked outside of that pretty small
friend group ever. That was never suggested, by the way. Number
two. Number two, the issue that for that situation and why my
got leaked afterwards had nothing to do with those nudes being
shown to anybody. Her face wasn't in it or no, they were in one
of them. Um, but she had already sent those to other people.
That wasn't the issue. The issue was that she didn't like that
I called her ugly, which was really mean, by the way. Uh, I don't
fault her for getting super. She should have been, but the main
issue with that wasn't that I was like revenge or leaking nudes
or whatever. It was that I called her ugly. That was the huge
issue because she felt like I was being too faced, which I kind
of was. Also, by the way, this was like 13 years ago, I think
12 years ago. Um, yeah, something like that. But it doesn't really
matter. People are still going to perceive that as you No, I
think the vast majority of people don't. No, I don't think the
vast majority of people even know anything about that story because
again, 12 years ago, number one. And number two, even threatening
it, even if you're doing it in a like subtle little jokey way,
obviously people are going to think, "Yeah, you're probably going
to do it." Like are you think really you think me who's gotten
news from how many people or talked to how many people are thinking
like well 12 years ago uh when Destiny found this other chick
when he was like 23 years old uh you know he called this one
chick's face ugly and he got in huge trouble for it because she
blah blah blah. So I bet he's going to leak my nudes or even
though I didn't leak Anna's nudes or anything. I don't think
I leaked anything anybody ever like that. Like really? Are you
sure you're not just like inventing this in your mind because
this story sounds really good and compelling to you but it actually
makes no sense whatsoever? No, it makes sense. I think I think
you probably would have. But I didn't. You have no proof of that
whatsoever. Yeah, I think you would have if you thought you could
get away with it. Yeah. Okay. Evidence cited. Yeah. Crackpipe.
Okay. Anything else? Sure. Emory, do you would you what criticisms
did you have of me? [__] When you were talking,
you sound like you probably use an inhaler and you worship Mr.
Girl. Uh, and you think I apparently low tax. Um, you also spend
way too much time gossiping and obsessing over other people's
lives in a Discord channel on a Saturday night to ever claim
that somebody else is a loser or has no social life or is having
unfulfilling relationship seems like a
interesting combination of qualities. I guess first of all, I
don't know who Low Tax is at all. That was something spread around
by Chud. I've never heard of this low tax person in my life.
So, that's number one. I don't even know who the is. I don't
know. A lot of people are sending you a lying about that one.
I mean, that's fine. I just I don't know who that is. Okay. Why
would I lie about that? Also, I don't know. I don't know why.
If you're a Mr. Girl fan, literally anything's on the table.
I have no idea. I thought if I thought you him, I would be using
this as a criticism, wouldn't I? Oh, I don't know. I have no
idea. I don't know anything about it only stand to benefit me
in my argument to be like, "Yeah, I think you can blow tax. Here's
the reasons why." A a or you realize since then it was dumb and
you don't complain about anymore? I have no idea. I don't know.
Yeah. Somebody told me that you went on Mr. stream and you called
him and you said that Blow Tax's blood was on my hand because
I didn't respond to him on Discord or whatever. No. Oh, okay.
Well, maybe they mix up with somebody else. Is this in reference
to somebody you told the themselves or or not told the themselves,
but you basically were like, "Yeah, whatever you do, what you
want with your life when they're coming to you about considering
is that the person?" No. Okay, then I have no Yeah, I have no
clue. Wait, did you just reference the situation? No, I don't
know who the it is. Okay. Yeah. So, I think my other criticism
was the DOS kid. Do you have anything within the last decade?
Cuz you Yeah. You're saying that he's inept at building friendships
and known as a bridge burner. So, the inept at building friendships
part, what what's your evidence for that? He seems inept
burning bridge after bridge, just constantly escalating. Thanks
for the doesn't really need to be. For instance, with Kelly,
you were like microscopically like looking at Kelly's activity
on Spicy Chat and acting like she was colluding with them. Okay.
So,
A little psychotic, don't you think? Like those people can't
harm you. Okay. Anything else? Do you think that warrants an
apology to Kelly or an at least a mission of like, "Hey, I'm
I'm thinking like maybe I was a little too far there." Uh, no.
Are there any other situations we've got? So I my life and my
ability to manage my streaming stuff is a disaster because of
my the one situation with Nicole 12 or 13 years ago because the
DOS Kelly and Destiny have made up as far as I know by the way
because of Kelly Jean me
list out there so I don't know. Okay. Give me your one Give me
your top two greatest hits. Okay. I don't know why I'm in here
right now. Uh well I already told you I know. Okay. Yep. And
uh yeah I don't know. Do you think I have more or less positive
connections on average than like I think you have more negative
connections. I think like when people talk about you they usually
think like yeah that guy's like a sociopathic
loser who's like just like super psychotic and his community
is known as a bunch of harassers and yeah that's not a good image.
So okay do you think Lex Friedman thinks that? Um, no. But that's
because Lex Freeman doesn't probably pay too much in-depth attention
to stuff like that. Okay. Do you think Ben Shapiro, Jordan Peterson,
or Candace Owens thinks that? Um, the same. Actually, Lex would
probably be more clued in on something like that. I don't think
any of those people know anything about that. Do you think Adam
22 thinks that? I don't care what Adam22 thinks. He's like not
not a very good person. Do you think XQC or Mis thinks that?
Uh, yeah. Not very good people. Like I don't I don't think they
even care what you do. Who's a Who's a good person who has this
criticism of Destiny? Yeah. Who's somebody that I should be like,
"Oh, I hate that this guy has this like really scathing criticism
of me." I Well, we're going to disagree on who's good and who's
bad. Give me a couple. By the way, which by the way, you're not
the only person that I really don't like in the space. So, it's
not like
that point. Just the person you think is a good person who has
this criticism would be Yeah. Just give me a couple good people.
I'm like, "Oh, this person has a really negative opinion of me.
That should mean something to me. I don't I don't think it I
don't think it should mean anything to you. I'm just saying give
me two people. I know what you're saying. I'm saying give me
two people. I'm just telling you that's what your public image
is. You know, you're telling me what my public image is and I
just named all the largest I have and then you're trying to tell
me what public image so you obviously care. So it doesn't really
matter. You think that my public image is what good person thinks
you're psycho? Like it doesn't really matter. Well, I mean my
public image is something that's obviously important to me as
a streamer person, right? So, I'm thinking of all the like the
largest connections I have and how I'm viewed in those communities
and you just said none of those communities matter. So, I'm curious.
Oh, well, where is this? Do you think that it's like spicy chat?
Is that who I should care about? I don't even think he's in like
Discord anymore. What happened? Not in there. Not even in there.
Okay. Which Well, who what are the communities that I think you
think I should care about where my image is so tarnished? I'm
just saying what your your image is. I'm not saying you should
care. My image is where? I don't give a if you care. I'm just
telling you that's what your image is. Yeah, but my image is
that where? everywhere besides your own all of the people that
I dressed as little inner circle. Yeah, pretty much. Is Adam2
my inner circle? Yeah. Is the Daily Wire my inner circle? They're
closer closer connected to you in terms of professionalism. Yeah.
Okay. So, is like Abba or Lex? Are these like my inner circle?
Yeah, they're closer to your uh professional business. Yes. They're
not like David Pacman. Is David Pacman my inner is David Pacman
my inner circle? Again, another professional relationship and
he probably doesn't really pay attention. So, okay. So, my public
image isn't like all of the largest content creators that I know
and do content with. My public image is actually what you say
it is based on what what they say in back Discord rooms about
me or what? Yeah. I mean, there's a reason the reputation is
there. Wow. Okay. Every time I fans talk about me in chat, I
always excited to talk to him and I just feel depressed after
I do it. I got one I got one other guy. Hold on. I I got one
other guy. Oh, I just feel bad. Why aren't you in Chud's Discord
anymore,
I've first of all, I've never really been a fan of Chud and I've
never been a fan uh of
what? So, I got one of the guys. Are you still a fan? Are you
still a fan of Mr. Girl? Um, yeah. But like I don't I don't agree
with like 50% of what he says. Just like certain things. Okay.
Do you think he's a Mr. Girl? Almost certainly. So, yeah. Fractional
by his own admission. Yeah, we didn't seem to think that before.
Uh I hadn't heard the full context of the recounting of his activities
before. Quite convenient after like the whole bridge burn. You
think he's a himself? Well, that's because I had been introduced
to a clip that I'd never heard before, but we had had a specific
conversation about him being a quote unquote on my stream before
over one clip where he tells that story. And I said, "Yeah, you
got to be really careful about this because if you push too far
or whatever, I think I'm playing Dice Spear program. You can
find I don't want to misquote myself, but I'm pretty sure it's
something." Yeah, you can very easily be here. But then somebody
after they had a big falling out and people are obviously licking
more. I saw another retelling of that story by him. I was like,
"Oh, this sounds like full on. I'd never heard this angle of
the story before from him." You can say it's convenient. I mean,
maybe I was more incentivized to click bad clips. That's possible.
But I don't know. Like if you're implying that if I would have
seen the same clip before, if I would have said, "Oh, no. I'm
sure he's not a he just whatever." Or because even in the stuff
that he did present to me, I was like, "Yeah, there's like this
sounds like pretty bad. You got to be really careful." But I
just think you're pretty disingenuous. Like anytime like you
have a good rapport with somebody, you highlight their bad actions
in very good ways or you minimize it and then after you have
a bad relationship or bad rapport, you uh turn it the other way.
Okay. So, I mean, yeah, it's part of the game. It's not so
Okay. Emory, do you have any other like criticisms you want to
make real quick? Because Benny's here and I think Benny wants
uh to make some of a similar argument real quick. Oh boy. Sure.
Like I'm not a professional debate lord. Uh so I don't know if
it feels like you got like some monumental win here. That's fine.
Okay. All right. Thanks for coming on. I'm just chilling. So
have a Benny. How's it going? Hey guys. How you guys doing? Oh,
pretty good. How are you? I'm good. Yeah, I'm uh I don't I don't
necessarily want to hop on to any of the claims that Emory was
making specifically. I'll just say um as far as Destiny's personal
relationships go, obviously I don't know all the personal relationships
that he has, but like um I think if we look at Kelly in particular,
I think uh Destiny is like clearly like a narcissist and he's
unable to admit when he's wrong even when it's like clearly obvious.
Um, and I think that that probably negatively affects some of
the personal relationships that he has with people, specifically
people who have like a vested interest in having like a good
public image. I think he doesn't really care about other people's
public image and uh he's uh unwilling to admit when he's wrong.
But that's that's all I have to say. I mean, okay, to be a little
bit more specific, in the Kelly Jean situation, I don't agree
that, you know, based on what I heard about the insults that
you said that you were saying that you turned her down, but you
said that she was lying and then
information that said that she probably wasn't lying, specifically
that after you had left the chat, she um made some sort of comment
that indicates that you truly believe that and you never apologize
for calling her a liar. and you like obfuscated and you started
talking about some other stuff and you know you called her like
or something. I don't even know what you did but instead of apologizing
just saying okay you're right I'm sorry I shouldn't have called
you a liar you just like move on to the next thing and find a
way to condemn her again and um I heard Jay talk say that you
know you and Kelly might be good now but it doesn't change the
fact that the general impression from your audience is probably
that Kelly is a liar or um extremely manipulative or maybe she
could have just been wrong. Maybe she was wrong because of any
type of emotional issue that she might have or um maybe because
you've been, you know, callous towards her recently, but uh instead
of taking that perspective or apologizing for putting that perspective
out, you just like double down or you move on to the next point.
Am I wrong in anything that I just said? Uh my main issue was
when she leaked the insult that I said. So like not having the
context around it and not saying what else came alongside that
was misrepresenting that. Um,
that was my main point. Apparently, 30 minutes after I left,
she expressed some other issue with another insult I said. So,
maybe those were her true feelings. I still don't know if I believe
that or not, but my main issue was the uh context. You think
it's likely that I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Was the lack of context
surrounding the primary thing? That was always my biggest issue.
That was the number one problem that I had. Okay. Do you think
that it was likely that she um believed that? Not really. No,
not really. So you think that she's so Machavelian that 30 minutes
after you left she she made a message to so that there would
be plausible deniability later. You think you think that that's
more likely than end well for me is it? Uh I don't think she's
machavellian. No maybe when she reflected on it maybe she was
like oh well this felt weird or bad or whatever and then she
afterwards maybe had an idea about it. But at the time no I don't
think that was the impression but hey I could be wrong. I don't
live in her mind. So you know so she thought about it 30 minutes
after and that's that long. Well, that's what Justic reported
to me. Justical said that the messages were in the chat 30 minutes
after. No, we're talking about like we spoke on voice like after
you left and stuff. It wasn't like 30 minutes after you left.
Well, 30 minutes.
It wasn't like long after. It doesn't really matter though to
be honest. So, it wasn't very long after. And you think that
that was enough time for her to recontextualize all those messages
in like I I don't even understand what it is that you're saying.
Are you saying that she didn't believe it when she sent it or
or said it those messages? Uh I think that when I shouted a string
of insults at her, I don't think that she thought that like,
"Oh my god, he's implying that I turned her down." And then within
30 minutes she did. Um I don't even know if that was what was
said after 30 minutes in the voice chat. I think that the me
turning her down I think came from the August can also confirm
that I spoke about that uh being triggered by the comment in
the uh in the YouTube chat or whatever. Apparently the thing
that triggered her mentioned something on stream. So that did
also trigger me up that reasons. I think I think what is being
said is that she thought that you said that and then the comment.
Yeah. She felt like that rumor had been spread around after she
had already thought that you said that because of a message that
she saw that she saw in chat. So now I'm asking you, did you
think it was likely that she believed it when she said it or
do you think it was like some sort of Machavelian Machavelian
ploy in order to have plausible deniability after she makes this
accusation about you later on? I don't think she's Mchavelian.
Okay. So then so then she meant it when she said it and then
she wasn't lying, right? So then she'll apologize for saying
that she lied. I don't First of all, I'm not apologizing because
uh number one, you don't have to say [__] You don't
have to say me. You just say Kelly. I'm not I'm not I'm not the
one I'm not the one that you said something about just existing.
Yeah. And then uh number two, yeah, I've never said she's mocky
villain. I just don't think she had that feeling at the time.
She might she might have and I could be wrong. That's possible.
There's no way for me to go back and verify. Okay. And what I'm
saying is if she talked about it later and then after reviewing
it later, she's like, "Wow, I wonder if he meant this." And then
she had that feeling later. I just don't think she had other
time. I think she did. What do you mean she had it later? She
said it 30 minutes after you left. Yeah, that's later. That's
how time works.
30 minutes. 30 minutes is after, which means later. Yeah. prior
time. Correct. Yeah, you're right. That's that's a significant
amount of time such that you could think that Do you think that's
not a significant? It's not. Try holding your breath for 30 minutes.
See what happens. Report back to us. Do you think that holding
your breath is the same thing about is is the same thing as like
considering what somebody said to you and I say it was the same
thing. I was just curious if you can hold your breath for 30
minutes. I can't I don't think anybody can to be honest with
that attitude. Probably not. Why don't you try it? No, I'm good.
I think 30 minutes is a long time so I wouldn't try that. Okay.
I mean, look, you know, I feel like I asked you a very straight
and simple forward question. I'm just saying if she wasn't lying,
then there must be some other explanation why she said it. And
um I think the most reasonable explanation if she wasn't lying
is that um she actually just thought that that that it's true.
I mean, I don't But you're still unwilling to bite that bullet
or It's not It's not really that It's not like nothing big on
either of our lives is hinging on this. No, I didn't say that.
Anything big, you know, for either of your lives is hinging on
it. It's just I think it's just an example of your narcissist.
You think there is there a chance that she's where you're just
Is there a chance that she didn't feel that at the time? No.
No. No. It is. And what I'm saying is for that to be the case,
she would have to be like this plotting scheming person. No,
I don't think she would have to be a plotting scheming person.
So So you you said a string of insults. 30 minutes after she
said, "Oh, he's implying this thing." And what point are you
making by by saying that? that maybe at first she thought it
was just a string of insults and then later on she thought it
was as in I don't think at the time I don't think that she was
thinking um I don't think that she was thinking like oh is he
implying that he turned me down. She probably I feel like she
probably thought that later after she reflected on it and then
thought about it later and by later you mean 30 minutes later.
Yes. Okay. And so what point are you making by saying that? I'm
speaking about the message that you said she sent. You said that
she's a liar for saying that. And I'm saying my my big Hold on.
No, I've said a million times. I don't really that's not even
that's something I care that much about the big the quote unquote
liar. No, we're going to get to what you care about. I'm just
asking about that part cuz that's what you said and you never
apologize for it or took it back. I still feel the same way.
I'm not going to apologize. I understand. I understand. What
I'm saying is you think that after 30 minutes of looking at the
message that you sent that she wasn't looking at the message
I sent. I think that I already explained. Do you not are you
not understanding what I'm saying? I might not be. Okay. I said
I don't remember she said something that triggered the out of
me and then I hurled a string of four or five insults at her
and then I think she got upset about the insults I said and said
you know you're digging in on personal stuff that I think you
said you wouldn't or you shouldn't be or you went way too hard
or something like that. I don't remember exactly. Um and then
I I don't even remember if we continue the conversation or if
I if I hung out for 10 or 20 more minutes or I left after. I'm
not sure. I don't remember. It was a private chat or whatever.
And then apparently 30 minutes later, u I don't know what was
said because this is reported to me by Egyptical and apparently
pretty Tony and August might have heard this, but apparently
as she's talking to them, she says something about like, "Oh,
I guess when Steven said this, was he implying that he turned
me down or something or maybe?" And then at that point she's
like, "Oh, wait. I don't know if he's I I don't know cuz I didn't
hear this." And obviously there's no text message or whatever.
But at the time when I said all the insults, I don't know if
she I didn't feel like she legitimately thought that I was implying
that I turned her down. I just don't feel that. I didn't feel
that at the time. Maybe she did feel it and she didn't express
it and she only expressed it later. But there's no way for me
to know that and it's not even like a big claim. I just dis I
just don't think that happened. But there's no way for me to
know. There's no way for her to convince me. Like I don't know.
I mean is just to call Tony and August saying that I'd said this
not like good enough proof. I don't get it. You're saying because
when you said it initially, she didn't mention that she felt
this way. And then 30 minutes later when she did mention that
she felt this way that somehow this is a lie. Just for the record,
that was me stewing on things because I was angry. Okay. So,
when she says that she was stewing on things, that seems to further
my idea that she probably didn't think about the time. She just
kind of was reflecting on it. She was like, "You know what? I
wonder if this or that." And that's where she was stewing on
things while she was still in the call as in like seconds and
didn't really want to express why. And on top of that, you you
said that she lied when she said it. I'm that's all that's the
only thing that I'm challenging. The fact that you said that
she lied. Well, because I feel like she's not being honest. Yeah.
Okay. So you so so then this is the question I have again. After
30 minutes, do you think that she like came up with this plan?
No. I Why do you keep going to the plan? You understand like
not everybody has to be like Mchavellian or creating diabolical
schemes. People can just like have a different feeling about
something later. That would be my what I if somebody has a feeling
if somebody has a feeling a different feeling about something
later. How does that make them a liar? I don't know. Maybe it
wouldn't make them a liar. Okay. Well, it would make them a liar
if they had the feeling initially, but then they said later on
like Wait, it would make them a liar of what? If they said they
initially had the feeling, and I feel like they didn't initially
have the feeling. But No, no, no. You weren't calling a liar
because she uh uh because she didn't say that she initially had
the feeling. You're saying that she's a liar because you don't
believe that she believed what she The main point for the liar
thing was that I felt like she left out context when she presented
my insult on stream. Okay, that was the main liar claim. Whether
or not she felt it at the time, it was like that's like a super
minor. I don't even feel that strongly about it. Okay, let's
let's move let's move on to that claim. If she did believe what
she said when she said it. Um
why why would any additional context matter? Like if somebody
says something to me, I don't start telling them about like what
what the weather was like that day. It it doesn't register as
context that would be relevant to the point that I'm making when
I'm telling the story. It seems like it seems like Kelly left
out that information because it wasn't relevant to the point
that she was making. Okay. Okay. And I think leaving out that
information like dramatically misrepresents the context. So I
thought it would be misrepresent it would be misrepresented if
she felt like the point of what you were saying is different
from the point that you were actually making. Right. Okay. So
maybe she maybe then she didn't misrepresent it. But her method
of mis of what she thought wasn't misrepresenting something would
in my mind be an obvious lie. But maybe she wasn't intending
to lie. So I don't know what you would call that. But it would
just be somebody being wrong. Yes. It would just be somebody
being wrong. Okay. Lying requires intent by definition. This
is this is when you say okay, but you could just be like, "Oh,
you know what? I guess it was unfair for me to call Kelly a liar."
Well, because I don't I don't believe that. I don't think Kelly
is that dumb. Okay. I think I said on stream, I think I literally
said, "Okay, well, there's two possibilities then. You're either
the most unbelievably stupid person ever and that you need like
a full-time career." I'm like that. Or you know that this is
obviously changing the context significantly if you leave out
everything else. I think you're a liar. There's no other option
possible. All right. Well, I I mean, look, that's all that I
had to say. Um, we made that clear. That definitely helped me.
Everybody else can decide for themselves
about how this conversation went. Um, yeah. Again, I'm not buying
into all of Emy's claims pretty much just because I don't have
like a mountain of evidence to be able to say that it's true,
but I do think that you're a narcissist and that you have a very,
very hard time admitting when you're wrong. True. I think that
this conversation is evidence of it. But I absolutely agree.
If I don't agree with you, I'm a narcissist. It's absolutely
true. That's not a narcissistic thing to believe, by the way.
But thank you. What? I didn't say anything like that. Okay.
Uh, all right. I mean, that's it. So, hey, thanks for coming
on, Benny. Peace out. Have a good one. See here.